Question 2--consider the same world as before with 4 states.
Now we're facing a situation in which there are 5 particles in A, 3 in B, 3 in C, and 1 in D.
We will now take a motion step. This is not about measurements, just motion.
Our robot moves with a 50% probability horizontally.
For example, if it was in D, it would move to C.
It moves with a 50% chance vertically but never diagonally,
and it never stays in the same cell.
After 1 motion step, how many particles do we expect in cell A, B, C, and D?
Answer the same for the asymptote.
If we move infinitely often, what is the distribution that we expect this to converge to?
I somewhat sloppily wrote "after infinite steps."
This is really what does it converge to in the end.